yeah what would you say is the main
component for you to
have the longevity because I mean listen
man we're talking going on 10 years now
right so like a lot of people's I mean
careers last a summer
two years you know like like I mean we
don't even gotta say names on the top of
your head the list goes on so many
artists and I'm like damn y'all had you
had a high year yeah and then you're
like what happened you know what I mean
like what do you think is uh been
pertinent to you staying relevant and
and you know for me I think just from a
fan is gross yeah the growth musically
is being myself yes embracing my flaws
bro not feeling like I supposed to be
that [ __ ] oh I support you know because
you're not wearing like a rapper costume
either I'm not a random rapper costume
I'm being myself you know what I'm
saying at the end of the day what as
before our mature and became this person
you will look look at I'm still in the
hood I'm doing all this [ __ ] and I'm
like how the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] doing
better than me and I know for a fact I
ain't a competitive person I don't
compare nobody which is important you
know because that is a flaw that's a
flaw I never look at nobody it's like
I'm supposed to be where they at yeah
you would look at a [ __ ] and be like
I'm supposed to be where he at now and
then next year where is he and you still
doing this I ain't never did this I
never shout out once you start looking
over him I always did this and this and
this and this and this because I always
bet it on myself you know I always
believed in myself and I always been
myself bro every every uh all through my
career I'm going through something
personally you know what I'm saying what
is adversity red is the music industry
ready is fighting the case whether it's
dealing with some [ __ ] at home I just
find a way to just be the best version
of myself when I'm out here being G
herbal right because I'm not g herbo
Herbert right right G herbo is the
basically the costume but I don't put on
a rapper costume I'm not trying to BG
herbo because I am G herbo that's me
automatically I am that but at the end
of the day I'm a man bro and that's
what's important to me so I always
focused on being that and just being the
best man I could be as long as I'm the
best man I could be I'm gonna always be
the best rap I could be that [ __ ] easy
bro I ain't no rap I'm a solid [ __ ] you
see what I'm saying that's what's
important to me and that's what people
gravitate to you know what I'm saying so
a lot of times people didn't really
catch on to the rap I ain't had no
plaques and all this crazy [ __ ] going on
you know what I'm saying I'm just not
really getting my plaques now I'm
getting my flowers now but I ain't never
asked for them I ain't one of them the
people who [ __ ] with me [ __ ] me if
it was for you it's for you well you
know what it is a lot of people use that
kind of [ __ ] as a way to give them like
like feel like they look at accolades
relationships props from other artists
as like a way to validate themselves
validate themselves and it's like bro
like if you know you're straight and you
know you're on your mission like
everything will come like at the end of
the day I always knew I was talking you
can't let outside [ __ ] validate who you
are and unfortunately like a lot of
people that's I mean I've been I've been
in that position in my life where I was
so worried about what everybody thought
or I have two you are always going to be
in that position when you call it you
worry about what everybody thinks but
the thing that made me stop caring is
it was always because of the internet if
I'm saying like the people that I deal
with on the day-to-day where there's
somebody I work with some my first time
meeting somebody My Mother My Girl my
kids right my girl mother family
everybody loved me when they meet me and
I started to think like I mean I'm a
solid [ __ ] I ain't never really had
nobody really say nothing bad about me
like in the streets my name always been
good even in the music industry in the
music industry as you know it's fake as
[ __ ] yeah I don't know anybody who's
ever said anything bad about you my name
good I'll help you bro cause I just
focus on being a solid dude right
personally my name good and the industry
my name good so it's like I can't really
care about what nobody said about me
because I ain't perfect I'm gonna [ __ ]
up of course so if I embrace my flaws
and just try to be the best version of
myself I'ma always be good and that's
why I never fed into like internet [ __ ]
my name's solid bro would always been
solid no matter what I did whether I was
in the streets every day in the industry
at home my name always been solid with
my flaws every [ __ ] up I ever had in my
life life my name still always remains
silent and that's what's important to me
that's all I really care about